Evet canlarım selamlar. Hemen bu derste
ne yapıyoruz? Orta Çağ'da ticaret
yolları diyoruz. Biz burada eski çağdan
beri var olan o kral yolundan, ipek
yolundan, Türk yolundan, baharat
yolundan bahsedeceğiz. Bu ticaret
yolları neden var biliyor musunuz? O
dönemde canlarım insanlar elinde bulunan
artı ürünleri başka bölgelere aktarmak,
ellerinde olmayan malları temin etmek
amacıyla faaliyet yürütüyorlar. Ve bu
ticaret yolları üzerinde de özellikle
kervansaylar yapılıyor. Böyle tüccarlar
ticaret yapacakları zaman böyle üç gün
işte yiyip içip dinlenebilecekleri,
konaklayabilecekleri, atlarına,
develerine yem yedirebilecekleri bir
ortam görüyorlar. Peki bu ticaret
yapıldıkça bu ticaret yolları aktif bir
şekilde kullanıldıkça ne oluyor?
İnsanlarda kültürel etkileşim yaşanıyor.
Yani insanlar birbirinin ne yediğini
öğrenebiliyor, ne giydiklerini
görebiliyor. Ya da ellerinde ne var,
bende ne var, ne yok bunun çıkarımında
bulunabiliyor ve etkileşime açık bir
ortam haline geliyor. Zaten dünyada
böyle toplumların kültürel etkileşim
yaşamasını sağlayan birkaç gelişme
vardır. Bunların başında ticaret
geliyor. Bunun dışında savaşlar geliyor
ve göç hareketleri yani toplumların bir
yerden bir yere göç etmesi de
birbirleriyle ilişki kurmasını sağlıyor.
Bunlara dikkat edersiniz. Yani ticaret
demek sadece ticaret yolları üzerinde
ticaret yapmak sadece ekonomik bir veri
getirmiyor. Onu demek istiyorum. Ne
getiriyor? Mesela toplumların hangi
teknolojide olduklarını, ne
giydiklerini, ne yediklerini, ne
içtiklerini görebiliyorsun. Dolayısıyla
sadece mal taşınmıyor. Bilgiler,
fikirler, inançlar da bu şekilde
karşılıklı yer değiştiriyor, taşınıyor,
etkileşim oluyor. Burada tamamız. Şimdi
ticaret yollarının devletlere etkileri
neler? Yani devletler bu ticareti
yaparken ne gibi kazanımlar elde ediyor?
ya da ne kaybediyor, ne oluyor ona
bakalım. Bakın şimdi ticaret yolları bir
kere ekonomilerin gelişmesini sağlıyor.
Burada tamamız zaten. Toplumların
şekillenmesinde önemli bir yere sahip.
Bakın burası önemli. farklı bölgelerdeki
üretim fazlaları artı ürünler ticaret
yoluyla diğer bölgelere taşınıyor.
Böylece ekonomik büyümeler sağlanıyor.
Ticaret farklı kültürlerin bir araya
gelmesine, etkileşimin olmasına ortam
hazırlıyor. Farklı bölgelerdeki
teknolojik gelişmeler ticaret yoluyla
diğer bölgelere geçiyor. Ticaret
yollarını kontrol eden devletler
ekonomik gelir, siyasi güç elde
ediyorlar. Ki bunun örnekleri çok.
Mesela Asya Hunları ipek Yoluna hakim
olduğu zamanlarda Çin üzerine hakimiyet
kurabiliyor. Onu baskı altına
alabiliyor. Zor duruma düşürebiliyor. Bu
açıdan önemli. Ticaret yolları üzerinde
şehirler ekonomik faaliyetlerin
yoğunlaşmasıyla büyümüş ve gelişmiştir
tabii ki normal olarak. Peki ticaret
yollarında önemli noktalar bakın bir
kere ticaret yollarının rotaları yani
güzergahları üzerinde coğrafi engeller
bulunabiliyor. Dağlar, çöller, nehirler
gibi değil mi? büyük çöle denk
gelebiliyorsun. E o zaman sen rotanı,
güzergahını buna göre
şekillendiriyorsun. Mesela İpek Yolunda
Taklaakan Çölü var canlarım. Taklaakan
çölü Çin topraklarında. E bu çölden
geçemez ki insanlar. Ne yapıyorsun?
Güzergahı buna göre belirliyorsun.
Ticaret yolları genellikle siyasi güç
merkezlerinin bulunduğu bölgelerden
geçmiş. Yani hangi devlet o bölgede
güçlüyse o devletin güzergahına göre bir
yol haritası çiziliyor. Devletler de
oradan ne yapıyor? Kazanım elde ediyor.
E peki bu şekilde olursa ne olur? O
devlet ticaretin güvenliğini sağlamış
olur. Hem de belirlenen merkezlerin
ekonomik anlamda güçlenmesi sağlanır. Bu
açıdan önemli. Ticaret yolları
üzerindeki şehirler genellikle kültürel
ve dini merkezler olmuş. Bu durum farklı
kültürlerin etkileşimini ve kültürlerin
ortaya çıkmasını ne yapmış? Sağlamış.
Peki arkadaşlar ticaret yollarının
güzergahının belirlenmesinde neler
etkili? Su kaynakları. Bir kere su
kaynakları özellikle belirlenmek,
görülmek isteniyor. Yani tüccarlar
ticaret yapacakları zaman develeriyle,
atlarıyla, katırlarıyla yol gittikleri
zaman su kaynağına rastlamak isterler.
Dolayısıyla ticaret yolları su
kaynaklarının çevresinde belirlenmeye
çalışılmış. Arazinin geçilebilirliği
yani dağ var mı, çöl var mı? Arazinin
engebe durumu nedir? Buna bakılmış.
İklim koşulları bakın sıcaklık, yağış
gibi iklim koşulları ticaret yollarının
güzergahını belirleyen önemli
noktalardan biridir. Çok yüksek
bölgelerden mesela ticaret yolunu
geçirmezsin. Çünkü ne olur? Mesela kışın
çok soğuk olabilir. Ticaret aksayabilir.
Buna göre iklim koşulları da
değerlendirilmiş. Siyasi durum bakın her
zaman savaşların olduğu, istikrarın
sağlanamadığı bir bölge düşünün.
Çatışmalar olabiliyor. İşte güvensizlik
ortamı var. Ya sen ticaret yolunu oradan
geçirir misin? Hayır. O zaman o bölgenin
özellikle siyasi istikrarına bakılıyor.
Orada güçlü, egemen bir devlet varsa ona
göre sağlıklı, güvenli bir ticaret
ortamı daha kolay sağlanacaktır. Böyle
düşünebilirsin. Ekonomik faktörler
canlarım. Yani bir ürünün bulunduğu ve
yola çıkarılacak bir malın olmadığı bir
yerde ticaret yapılır mı? Mesela ipek
yolu niye Çin'den başlıyor? Çünkü
Çin'deki ipek güzergahı olarak batıya
doğru gönderiliyor. Değil mi? Ana kaynak
nerede? Çin'de ya da Kürk yoluna
baktığımız zaman Kürt taşınıyor. Demek
ki kaynağa göre de ticaret yolu
belirleniyor. Kültürel etkiler de zaten
nedir? Farklı kültürlerin etkileşim
içerisine girmesi ticaret yollarının
gelişmesinde katkı sağlamıştır. Şimdi
canlarım gelelim ticaret yollarına. Kral
yoluyla başlıyorum. Bir kere eski çağın
en önemli yolu kral yoluydu. Bakın,
Lidyalılarla Perslerin sınırları
arasında önemli bir güzergahtır.
Bakıyorum İzmir yakınındaki Sart
kentinden yani Manisa çevresinde Salihli
bölgesinde bulunan Sart kentinden
başlamış. Perslerin Sus kentine kadar
gidiyor. Arkadaşlar bu SS kenti Elam
medeniyetine de başkentlik yapmıştır.
Aklınızda olsun. Yani sadece Perslerin
merkezleri arasında yer almıyor. Demek
ki güzergah neymiş? Batı Anadolu'dan
başlamış İran'a kadar gitmiş kral yolu.
Önemli bir ticaret yoludur. Zaten 1.
Darius Pers kralı 1. Darius zamanında bu
ticaret yolu mükemmel bir hale
getirilmiş ama daha öncesinde de zaten
ticaret yapılıyormuş. Peki canlarım Orta
Çağ döneminde aktif olan, faaliyet
yürütülen ticaret yollarına baktığımız
zaman bakın kürk yolu, ipek yolu ve
baharat yolu önümüze çıkıyor. Şimdi
bunları değerlendirelim. Bakın, "İpek
Yolu deyince Çin topraklarından
başlıyor. Doğu Türkistan, Moğolistan,
Kazakistan, Özbekistan, Kırgızistan,
Türkmenistan'ı geçtikten sonra Hazar
Denizi'ne ulaşıyor. Oradan Anadolu
kıyılarından liman kentlerine ulaşıyor.
Bak Çin'den başlıyor ve batıya doğru bu
şekilde geliyor. Bu hangi yolmuş? Bu
ipek yoluymuş. Zaten en aktif o dönemde
bu canlarım. İpek Yolunda Avrupalılar
Çin'in en önemli ihraç ürünleri olan
başta İpek olmak üzere değerli taşları,
porselenleri, cam eşyaları, kağıdı ne
yapıyor? Doğudan batıya doğru bu yolla
aktarıyor. Peki nota bakalım. Doğu ile
batı kültürü arasındaki etkileşimi tarih
boyunca sağlamış olan bu yol, alternatif
güzergahların bulunmasıyla birlikte
önemini kaybetmiş ama son yıllarda
yeniden dünya gündemine taşınmış. Niye?
Çünkü Çin dünyanın en büyük ulaşım
projesi olarak görülen tek kuşak ya da
tek yol yani modern ipek yol projesini
hayata geçirmek adına önemli adımlar
atıyor. Proje başta Çin olmak üzere
bağımsızlıklarını kazandıktan sonra
dünya ile ekonomik entegrasyona öncelik
veren Orta Asya Türk Cumhuriyetleri ile
Türkiye, İran ve Rusya gibi önemli
ülkeleri içeriyor canlarım. 91'de
özellikle SSCB denilen bir devlet vardı.
Sovyet Sosyalist Cumhuriyetler Birliği.
O devlet parçalandıktan sonra
Türkistan'da bir sürü Türk devleti
kuruldu. Bak Azerbaycan, Özbekistan,
Kırgızistan, Türkmenistan, Kazakistan.
Bunların hepsi Türk devletiydi. Ve Orta
Asya sınırlarında yaşadıkları için
günümüzdeki bu proje o devletleri de ne
yapıyormuş? İlgilendiriyormuş. Peki
siyasi etkileri diyorum. Orta Çağ
boyunca birçok devlet ipek yolunu
kontrol etmek için mücadele etmiş.
Özellikle canlarım Tabgaç Türkleri belli
bir dönem İpek Yolu için mücadele etmiş.
O bölgelere hakim olmuş. Ama asıl
mücadele ne zaman biliyor musunuz?
Bunlarla Çinliler arasında. Daha
sonrasında baktığımız zaman İpek Yolu
hakimiyeti için Göktürk Devleti de
faaliyet yürütmüş. Özellikle Akunlarla,
Bizans ve Sasanilerle bu yüzden
ilişkiler kurmuş. Yeri gelince de
savaşlar yapmış. Hatta şöyle yapmış.
Önce Göktürkler gitmiş Sasanhanilerle
işbirliği yapmış. Akunları yenmiş İpek
Yolunda. Daha sonra Sasaniler İpek
Yolunda güçlenince ne yapmış? Göktürkler
gitmiş bu sefer Bizans'ta işbirliği
yapmış. Sasanileri yenmiş. Demek ki
diplomatik faaliyetler de bu süreçte
yürütülmüş. Ekonomik açıdan baktığımız
zaman ipek yolu eski çağlardan orta
çağın sonuna kadar doğu batı şeklinde
transit bir yol olarak kullanılıyor.
İpek ve ipekli kumaşlar Çin'den üretilip
kervanlarla batıya doğru taşınıyor ve
ticaret yazın kışın aksamadan devam
ediyor. Çünkü dünya ticareti buradan
dönüyor. Tabii yol üzerinde bir devlet
varsa ki var değil mi? oralara hakim
olmak için bir sürü devlet kuruluyor. Bu
devletler hem ekonomik hem de siyasi
anlamda inanılmaz güç kazanıyor. Bunu
bir koz olarak diğer devletlere karşı
kullanıyor. Kültürel etkilerine
baktığımız zaman zaten farklı
toplumların bir araya geldiği,
fikirlerin, kültürlerin etkileşime
uğradığı, insanların kaynaştığı bir
noktada. Gelelim baharat yoluna.
Hindistan'dan başlayan baharat yolu İran
Körfezi yoluyla Irak'a, Yemen
kıyılarına, Kızıldeniz üzerinden Süveyş
ve Akabe'ye Ürdün bölgesi buralara
karayoluyla gidiyor. Sonra Doğu Akdeniz
limanlarından mallar taşınıyor. Bakalım
nasılmış. Baharat yolu dediğimiz
Hindistan'dan böyle gelmiş. İran körfezi
dediğimiz yer burası. Bak Mısır
topraklarına Anadolu'ya kadar uğrayan
yol. Sonra da bu zaten Akdeniz
limanlarından baharatlar dünya
ticaretine, dünya devletlerine
ulaştırılmış o dönemlerde. O zaman
canlarım, İpek Yolu güzergahında aşağı
yukarı hangi devletler var? Baharat yolu
güzergahında hangi devletler, hangi
güzergahlar var? Bunlara dikkat
etmenizde fayda var. Peki baharat yolu
adını taşıyan bu yolda ne taşınıyor?
Tarçın. Çok önemli baharatlardan bir
tanesi kakule, küçük hindistan cevizi,
öd ağacı, çörek otu, zencefil, karanfil,
sandal ağacı, karabiber gibi baharatlar.
Yani taşımada kolay ama pahada değerde
ağır şeyler taşınıyor. Aklınızda olsun.
Gelelim baharat yoluunun devletleri
etkisine, siyasi etkileri. Uzun bir süre
Roma İmparatorluğu'un hakimiyetinde
bulunan bu baharat yolu, özellikle Mısır
coğrafyası, Romalıların Ortadoğu'dan
çekilmesiyle Müslümanların kontrolüne
geçiyor. Mesela canlıların baharat
yolunu özellikle Osmanlı döneminde Yavuz
Sultan Selim hakim oluyor. Aklımızda
olsun. ekonomik etkilerine baktığımız
zaman İskenderiye Mısır'ın bir önemli
bir kenti. İskenderiye Hindistan'dan
gelen baharatın Akdeniz'e açıldığı,
Avrupa'ya ihraç edildiği yani
gönderildiği, satıldığı bir yermiş, bir
limanmış. Ekonomik etkilerinden devam
ediyorum. Roma ve Bizans'ın, Batı Roma
ve Doğu Roma yani Bizans'ın lüks tüketim
merakı bu ticaretin artmasına neden
olmuş. Yani Hindistan'daki baharatlar
canlarım Orta Çağ'da en değerli ürünler
ve kendini toparlamış ayakta güçlü duran
devletler orada ne var onu çok merak
ediyor ve denedikten sonra da baharata
gerçekten alışıyorlar. Sürekli
istiyorlar ve o yüzden hiç aksamadan
baharat yolu aktif bir şekilde
kullanılıyor. Baharatlar İskenderiye
limanından İstanbul'a getirilirdi.
Öncelikle sarayın ihtiyacı karşılanıp
daha sonra kalanlar halka sunulurdu. Bu
da ilginç. kültürel etkileri. Müslüman
tüccarlar baharat ticaretinde önemli bir
rol oynuyorlar. Kültürel etkileşimi
artırıyorlar. Ticaret o zaman kültürel
etkileşim için dil ya da dinin yayılımı
için önemli bir araç olmuş. Toplumlar bu
şekilde kültürel etkileşim yaşamışlar.
Gelelim Kürk yoluna canlarım. Adından
belli ne taşınıyor burada? Kür
taşınıyor. Bakın ipek ve baharat yolları
kadar işlek bir yol değil bu. Çünkü bir
kere soğuk bir coğrafya. Sibirya bölgesi
bu. Rusya, günümüzdeki Rusya'nın da
kuzeyi Kürk yolunun olduğu bölge. Bakın
Don Nehrinin denize döküldüğü yerden
başlayıp Ural Dağları Güney Sibirya
ormanları sınırından Altaylara, Sayan
dağları üzerinden Çin'e ve Amur Nehrine
ulaşan bir güzergahmış. Bakalım neresi
ya? Hoca ne diyor? Bak Çin toprakları
burası ya canlarım. Böyle kuzey
bölgelerinden soğuk coğrafyalardan
geçiyorsun. Sonra Karadeniz'in kuzeyine
uğruyorsun. Buradan ne taşınıyor?
Sibirya'daki kürkler taşınıyor. E ben de
diyorum ki bak İpek Yolu ve Baharat yolu
gibi burası o kadar aktif değilmiş. Bunu
söylemek istiyorum. Neden? Coğrafi ve
iklim şartları. Bundan dolayı ticaret
yolları üzerinde tüccarların konaklaması
amacıyla 30-40 km mesafelerde kervan
saraylar yapılıyor. Neden kervan
saraylar 30-40 km mesafelerde yapılıyor?
Genelde canlarım hayvanların, develerin,
katırların, atların yorulma mesafesi
hesaplanıyor. Tüccarların, tacirlerin
durumu hesaplanıyor. Ona göre bir
mesafeyle kervansaraylar yani dinlenme
tesisleri yapılıyor. Şimdi bakalım
aşağıda verilen kervansaray görselinden
hareketle verilen kutulardaki ilgili
alanlardaki özellikleri yazalım. Hemen
kervan saray'ı bir inceleyin. Zaten ben
cevapları doldurdum. Birlikte
değerlendirelim. Bir kere ekonomik
anlamda şunu yazabiliriz. ticaret
yolları üzerinde bulunarak tüccarlara
konaklama ve mal değişim imkanı
sağlamıştır. Kimin elinde ne varsa
diğerine onu satmış. Ne yoksa da onu
alıp gelmiş. Bu kadar basit. Sosyal
açıdan baktığım zaman bu kervan saraylar
bak farklı bölgelerden insanların bir
araya gelmesi, birbirini tanıması,
kültürel etkileşim yaşamasını
sağlamıştır. Buna olanak sağlamış. Sanat
açısından baktığımız zaman kervansaray
yapımı taş işçiliği, kemerler, taş
sütunlar gibi dönemin mimari öğelerini
yansıtmıştır. Yani sanat anlayışını
ifade etmiştir. Güvenlik açısından
bakacaksam kervansaray şimdi yüksek
duvarlarla çevrili olduğu için canlarım
bir kere güvenli bir alandır.
Tüccarların, malların, hayvanların
korunmasını sağlar. Ticaretin aksamadan
yapılmasını sağlar. Yolcuların
dinlenmesini, yemek yemelerini,
barınmalarını sağlar. hem de 3 gün
ücretsiz yerler içerler, barınırlar. Bu
açıdan da sosyal devlet özelliği taşır.
8. etkinliğe bakıyorum. Aşağıdaki
soruları metne göre cevaplayalım. Önce
bir okuyayım. Orta Çağ'da kervanlar
karayoluyla insan ve mal taşımacılığı
yapan konvoylardı. Böyle peş peşe
sıralanır giderlerdi. Kervanlarda taşıma
maşı, at, deve ve katırlarla yapılırdı.
Kervanlar için en ideal hayvan zor
koşullarda yük taşıyabilen develerdi.
Yetişkin bir deve bir atın veya katırın
taşıdığının iki katı kadar yük
taşıyabilir. Bununla birlikte deve yavaş
yürüdüğü için uygun bir binek hayvanı
değildir. Bak yük taşımakta onun üstüne
yok ama taşımacılıkta hani böyle seni
bir yere ulaştıracaksa binek hayvan
olarak kullanıyorsan çok yavaştır. Ama
örgücünde oturtuğu sularla çok uzun
mesafeler katedebiliyor. ağır yükler
taşıyabiliyor. Yani olumlu tarafı da
var, olumsuz tarafı da var. Kervanlar
sıcaktan kaçınmak, konaklama yerine
sabah saatlerinde varabilmek için
genellikle gece yolculuğu yaparlar.
Araziyi ve hava koşullarına göre
değişmekle birlikte kervan günde 30-50
km arası yol gidebiliyor. Kervanlarla
daha çok baharat, değerli taşlar,
kumaşlar gibi yükte hafif ama lüks
mallar yani değerde fazla pahalı mallar
taşınıyormuş. Ağırlığı fazla olan temel
ihtiyaç maddelerinin taşınmasındaysa
mümkün olabildiğince deniz yolu tercih
ediliyor. Günümüzde de deniz yolu
gerçekten ağır ürünlerin taşınmasında
tercih ediliyor. Bakalım şimdi Orta
Çağ'da ticari faaliyetlerin kervanlarda
taşıma aracı olarak hangi hayvanlar
kullanılmış? At, deve ve katır zaten.
Hatta ne dedim? En sağlamı ağır yük
taşıyanı deveymiş. Kervanlarda yükte
hafif eşyalar taşınmasının nedeni nedir?
Ona bakalım. Hemen bakalım. Baharat,
değerli taş, kumaş gibi mallar bakın
değerli mallardır ama taşınması kolay
mallardır. O yüzden taşınması kolay
olduğu için bunlar tercih edilmiş ve
amelelik, boşuna amelelik yapılmamış.
Yani kervanlarda deve kullanılmasının
olumlu olumsuz yönü nedir? Zaten
biliyoruz. Olumlu yönü şu. Zor
koşullarda çok yük taşıyabiliyor.
Dayanıklı bir at ya da katırdan çok daha
fazla yük taşıyor. Ama olumsuz tarafı ne
dedim? Yavaş yürüdüğü için bir binek
hayvanı olarak tercih edilmiyor. Çünkü
yavaş yürüyerek gidiyor gideceği yere. O
yüzden binek hayvanı olarak değil taşıma
aracı olarak görülüyor develer. Gelelim
son etkinliğimize. 9. etkinliğimizi
okuyorum canlarım. Anadolu'da geçmişte
doğudan batıya, güneyden kuzeye birçok
güzergahta yaptırılan yüzlerce
kervansaray Türklerin ticarete verdiği
önemi, konukseverliği ve sosyal devlet
anlayışını yansıtan en önemli eserler
arasında yer alıyor. Önce sınır
boylarında askeri amaçla yapılan bu
yapılar daha sonra tekkelerin,
zaviyelerin yani dini mekanların ve
hanılara dönüşmüş. İlk kervansaray
Gazneli Mahmut döneminde yapılmış. Daha
sonra Karahanlılar Büyük Selçuklu
döneminde Horasan bölgesinde çeşitli
kervan saraylar yapılmış. Selçuklu
Sultanları ticaretin gelişmesi için yol
emniyetine önem vermiş. Yaklaşık 30-40
km aralıklarla kervansaraylar
yaptırılmış. Anadolu yol güzergahında
kervanların konakladığı kervan
saraylarla donatılmıştır. Kervan
saraylar hem ticari mahiyette hem de
yerleşim alanları dışında olduğu için
her an düşman ve eşkıya taarruzuna maruz
kalabilirdi. Onun için daha çok içe
dönük karakterde yapılardır. Dıştan
masif yüksek duvarlarla çevrili ve tek
girişi olan çok güvenli yerlerde 3 güne
kadar ücretsiz kalınan yeme içme
hizmetlerinin ücretsiz olduğu yapılardı.
Bazı kervanaylarda doktorların ve
veterinerlerin hizmet verdiği
bilinmekte. Yani sağlık hizmetleri de
burada veriliyor. Bak güvenlik
sağlanıyor. Yeme içme ücretsiz. Sağlık
hizmetleri de var. Müthiş bir şey.
Kervansay.
Kervansarayların yapılış amaçları
nelerdir? Ticaretin gelişmesini
sağlamak, konaklama hizmeti sağlamak,
hatta tüccarların güvenliğini sağlamak
yazabilirsiniz. Kervan sarayları sosyal
devlet ilkesi açısından yorumlayacaksak
eğer 3 güne kadar ücretsiz konaklama
imkanı varsa, doktor ve sağlık
hizmetleri varsa, e o zaman insanların
ihtiyacını karşılıyorsa bu sosyal devlet
anlayışını yansıtan bir mimari yapıdır.
Gelelim 10. etkinliğe. Aşağıdaki ticaret
yolları haritasından hareketle İpek ve
Baharat ticaret yolları güzergahında
günümüzde hangi devletler vardır? Çok
güzel bir soru canlarım. Bunu
ezberleyemezsiniz ama mantığını
kurabilirsiniz. İpek Yolu Çin'den
başlayacağım. Batıya doğru gideceğim.
Bakalım. İpek Yolunda Çin, Kazakistan,
Kırgızistan, Özbekistan, İran, Türkiye
var. Böyle geldik. Türkiye'ye vardık.
Ben diyorum ki baharat yolunda da
Hindistan yani şuradan başladığımı
varsay. Pakistan yani şurası canlarım.
Suudi Arabistan yani burası canlarım.
Yemen, Mısır, Türkiye. Mısır zaten
burası. Yemen de şurası. E o zaman ne
güzel. Her halükarda olay bizde bitiyor.
Bizden de denizler aracılığıyla başka
bölgelere aktarılıyor. Evet canlarım
dersimiz bu kadardı. Etkinliklerimizi de
çözdük. Şimdi bir konumuz daha kaldı.
Onu da anlatacağım. Ondan sonra genel
tekrar videomuz gelecek. Sonra yazılı
hazırlık videosuyla karşınızda olacağım.
Emeklerime karşılık videoyu beğenmeyi,
abone değilsen abone olmayı unutma. Çok
güzel kitaplar hazırlıyorum size. 10.
sınıf olduğunuzda kullanabileceğiniz.
Onlara çok emek veriyorum. O yüzden
şimdiden bildirim zilini açın ki seneye
10. sınıf olduğunuzda birlikte
konularımızı düzenli bir şekilde
ilerletelim. Marif Modelde yeni sınav
sisteminde başarılara ulaşalım.
Seviliyorsunuz, kendinize iyi bakın.